the Joe Rogan experience Styles that's
one of the cool things about the sports
is there's so many different ways to
genetically like him Mariah Mariah yeah
Jose Aldo Brazilians guys fast which was
unfair fast for it what did you think
did you watch the mirai's all the fight
I was kind I was wandering out during it
so I kind of got to see kind of kind of
didn't so I never really watched it most
people pretty salty on the decision yeah
how you feel I didn't like it
yeah I thought although without them I
thought he looked he opened up with a
switch kick to the head and had all
those staggering a little bit Aldo
covered up and weathered the storm and
then Aldo started putting the pressure
on him and all those started hitting him
with big punches and really was
controlling the center of the Octagon
and really pressuring him and being very
aggressive and then he got taken down
the last couple of seconds of the first
round but nothing happened he just took
him down and hold him in my mind that
shouldn't mean much that don't mean
nothing that doesn't mean I get mad
about takedowns period and an MMA coz I
I understand how I can beat somebody up
for four minutes and 50 seconds and you
you take the last ten second you take me
down for last ten seconds you win though
you win the round it's crazy I think so
you have to take me down and if you're
not gonna advance you at least got a
crown upon me for 30 seconds 40 seconds
to make that legitimately takedown I
agree it should be something happens
when you go to the ground support 100%
you got to brutalize the guy or threaten
with the submission it's got to be
something
but with Malin and Josie Aldo if they
gave that first round to Marlon it's on
the basis of that high kick some strikes
landed but I thought Aldo did more and I
said although did more in the second
round and I thought all I thought all
the one to fight I thought it was close
but I thought all the won the fight if
he was more aggressive
everybody's tripping on him I was like
he looked good yeah although just have
high cheekbones then like and then he
was like leaving his facial hair for
like all five weeks so people's like oh
my god I look scared I'm like guys this
is how he looks this is a species ball
too you know that doesn't help help when
you have borne it
you know people just think he look crazy
already look well you know that was the
first fight that he ever had a
nutritionist for his whole that's I
heard that is crazy crazy like mad
that's what I heard I heard I heard his
meals when he's at 45 was just whatever
he wanted to eat like he's not like
eating whatever you wanted to he did it
I'm like yeah that's why this dude's one
of the grades all the time he's an
animal well he ate whatever he wanted
and then he just drained the [ __ ] out of
himself yeah exactly but he had some
times during his career where people
didn't think he was gonna be able to
make 45 anymore he's gonna have to go up
to 55 yeah so then the see him down at
35 was quite crazy but what I saw when I
saw him when he was staying pausing and
getting ready
I saw mussels yeah it wasn't like he was
like yeah you see some guys when they're
just there making a bad way yeah they
just look like [ __ ] yeah he just look
ripped no he looked good he look real
good you know even when I cuz I saw him
what do what did I see him I'll do an
immediate day or whatever early in the
week we even worked out me and him had
the same workout room for one of the
nights and we worked out together and
when I showed them III you know I'll
shake hand he pulling in a hug first
thing I go back to my was like guy hard
as a rock
he's gonna make weight when you when
you're that hard and you have muscle
it's much easy to cut water right when
you touch someone they saw he's like
yeah man you don't make peace be with
you people don't think that right I mean
we had a it's it's it's a we had a
conversation about that with the [ __ ] is
his name
it wasn't Dolce it was the other guy
I'll remember his name in a minute
Lockhart yes thank you George Lockhart
sorry George it's the weed I blame the
weed but Lockhart was saying that big
muscular guys there it's easier it's
easy to you you can suck you can suck
water out of someone who's muscular cuz
his muscle muscles gonna let go let go
to water but if you got fat fat is not
help hold on to everything right why you
fat
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] what is this let's just hold
on to it muscle is like once is
something bad like muscles won't even
hold on hold on to something bad if you
eat sugar you so muscular you feel sick
it's funny how different gods look on
the scale versus the next day like
Lombard was a good example like when he
would make 170 he looks so much smaller
on the scale on the next table like [ __ ]
because it's the same muscle yeah and
then muscle wants water yeah when you
put water into that day that bad boy my
god you look like a balloon yeah
[Applause]